et à peine les résultats connus les
candidats sont repartis en campagne
notamment du côté de la majorité
présidentielle les projections ne
garantissent pas à Emmanuel Macron une
majorité absolue la chef de fil de la
majorité elle-même candidate est
retournée désire sur ses terres
électorales du Calvados où on va
retrouver Guillaume Balard bonjour
Guillaume merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous directeurs départementales de
Ouest-France vous êtes à Caen et on va
dire un mot d'abord pour appeler le
score d'Elizabeth borne ce dimanche dans
la sixième circonscription du Calvados
et nous rappeler un petit peu quel est
le paysage politique de sa
circonscription
oui bonjour Elisabeth borne pour sa
première candidature en son nom
personnel a réussi son premier tour
puisqu'elle a remporté 34 32% des
suffrages donc près de 10 points de
différence face à son jeune concurrents
de la nuque Noé Gauchard et le candidat
du Rassemblement national lui qui avait
été pourtant maintenu au second tour en
2017 a été éliminé avec quand même 21%
des suffrages
ça veut dire que juste pour le second
tour Elisabeth borne et quand même en
position plutôt favorable elle est en
ballotage pour l'instant très favorable
il y a près de 5000 voix d'écart donc
reste à savoir maintenant où se
porteront les voix du rassemblement
national et des abstentionnistes est-ce
que ça sera votre protestataire ou pour
faire tomber également Elisabeth borne
puisque dans cette circonscription
rurale du Calvados on a bien vu l'enjeu
national depuis la candidature de la
première ministre justement Elisabeth
borne allait retourner très vite en
campagne puisque elle était de retour
sur ces terres du Calvados
oui elle est revenue hier dans la nuit
on lui avait reproché ses adversaires
mais également les journalistes locaux
faut bien de l'avouer le fait qu'elle
soit partie à Paris dès qu'elle a eu mis
son bulletin dans l'urne donc elle s'est
justifiée son adversaire de la nuque lui
n'était pas non plus présent dimanche
soir sur Vire puisqu'il a couru les
plateaux télés radio du fait justement
de la dimension nationale de l'élection
et du fait qu'il est un coup à jouer en
tous les cas rien à perdre
juste un mot sur comment s'est passé
hier sa visite dans le Calvados
Guillaume elle est allée tout de suite
dans une entreprise du côté de
Condé-sur-Noireau elle a prévu donc hier
on a reçu comme dans toutes les
rédactions
son agenda prévisionnel de Première
ministre pour la semaine et ensuite hier
soir on a reçu un autre agenda celui de
son équipe de campagne où on voit
qu'elle essaie de mettre des rendez-vous
sur le terrain pendant cette semaine
entre couper de d'aller-retours à Paris
et notamment par exemple mercredi matin
elle se rendra sur un marché dans une
commune de la circonscription
accompagnée par son prédécesseur
l'ancien député Alain Tourer et du coup
vous qui avez l'agenda du Calvados elle
a elle a prévu d'être beaucoup dans le
Calvados cette semaine
pour l'instant alors elle nous a assuré
hier qu'elle serait au maximum dans la
circonscription cette semaine pour
l'instant ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle
sera mercredi matin
sur le marché de Villers-Bocage et
ensuite les rasoirs des commerçants dans
une commune à côté mais dans le dans son
même agenda cette fois-ci de Première
ministre Édouard rentrer à Paris puisque
à 16h il est indiqué qu'elle doit
rencontrer
je ne sais je vais vous dire ça
madame Yelle Braun Pivet merci Guillaume
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
évidemment vous allez suivre toute la
semaine et ce sera à lire dans vos
éditions cette semaine d'entre-deux
tours notamment pour Elisabeth borne
candidate dans le Calvados et on suivra
tout ça avec vous merci beaucoup
Guillaume d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde la Une de Ouest-France
aujourd'hui une vague de chaleur avant
un été de canicule c'est la question qui
est posée à la Une de votre journal
merci Guillaume on le voit on l'entend
avec Guillaume et les abattement qui a
prévu une semaine avec des
allers-retours entre le Calvados et
Paris elle joue gros la première
ministre cette semaine oui elle joue
gros Guillaume Balard a rappelé qu'elle
avait fait plutôt un score honorable au
premier tour la première mise je n'ai
pas tout à fait la même lecture
j'estimais que en tant que première
ministre en tant que chef de la majorité
présidentielle enfin en tout cas chef du
groupe de la majorité présidentielle
membre du gouvernement chef du
gouvernement surtout elle aurait pu
estimer être un peu au-dessus bon elle
fait quand même un bon score elle est
prête 10 points au dessus de du candidat
de la nuque mais ça va être serré je
pense effectivement il le rappeler
Guillaume
il y a 5000 voix des quarts entre les
deux donc ça va être la campagne ça va
dépendre aussi de comment vont se
comporter les électeurs notamment de du
rassemblement national je l'ai pas
trouvé non plus vous allez me trouver
dur avec la première mise mais je l'ai
pas trouvé non plus vous savez quand on
est nommé Premier ministre des Anciens
quand même faire de la politique on est
censé on est censé animer un collectif
même politique qui est celui de
l'Assemblée nationale hier elle
réunissait par un zoom
de sur Internet l'ensemble des candidats
de la majorité on peut pas dire qu'elle
soit une une leader quoi une leader qui
qui emporte les foules et qui et qui
fasse de la politique et on voit bien
qu'elle essaie d'envoyer ses coups à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de manière assez peu
à droite avec même des journalistes
jusqu'à l'AFP qui est obligé de faire
des des des mentis de certaines
caricatures qui sont faites les premiers
pas globalement de la première mise sont
pas extraordinaires d'abord parce qu'il
y a pas de proposition il y a pas de
vision qui sont avancées c'est beaucoup
reproché à la majorité présidentielle de
l'avancée masqué au cours de ces
législatives on sait pas très bien quel
est le projet a pas la réforme des
retraites à 65 ans
c'est compliqué pour elle je trouve
c'est compliqué pour la majorité aussi
on l'a vu c'est quand même une défaite
ce premier tour pour pour cette majorité
on va voir ce que ça donnera dimanche
prochain et j'imagine que Dominique à
très envie de vous répondre
j'écoute ça avec avec un petit sourire
non pas que ce je ne prenne pas ça au
sérieux mais ne faites pas semblant de
découvrir la personnalité
qui choisit
ce que vous avez cocktail de gentillesse
ou d'amabilité que vous avez adressé la
première minute ne faites pas semblant
de découvrir aujourd'hui à l'issue du
premier tour le les traits de caractère
politique et personnel de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas beaucoup connu des Français et
qui est effectivement historiquement si
je puis dire plus techno que pur
politique nous le savons c'est un choix
qui a été fait par qui a été fait par
Emmanuel Macron donc ne faites pas
semblant de découvrir elle a fait une
bonne performance et effectivement comme
vous samedi beaucoup va dépendre
normalement elle va être élue et ce
serait une catastrophe pour elle
accessoirement pour la majorité s'il en
était autrement mais ça je ne retiens
pas si hypothèse dans le cas précis dans
le cas précis mais effectivement comme
vous l'avez dit beaucoup va dépendre du
choix des électeurs du rassemblement
national c'est intéressant leur candidat
est éliminé que vont-ils choisir
s'abstenir ou faire je pense que vous
devez l'appel du pied vous avez fait un
appel de pied en leur direction ou pas
qui
je suis journaliste je sers
j'observe effectivement l'électorat de
Marine Le Pen peut constituer parfois un
bloc anti Macron parfois un bloc anti
Mélenchon je pense que l'électoral
Marine Le Pen elle a besoin résultat
et justement on va en parler puisque
Samia Elizabeth borne hier elle a appelé
une nouvelle fois à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite en cas de duel entre la
nuque et le rassemblement national oui
c'est assez ambiguant Oriane parce qu'en
fait ce sera pas systématiquement un
barrage ce sera du cas par cas elle a
précisé Isabelle Borny la ligne à tenir
pas une seule voie ne doit aller au
rassemblement national à affirmer hier
donc Elisabeth borne depuis le Calvados
on pourrait croire que la consigne est
claire mais en fait non ça dépend du
candidat
quand on a un candidat républicain et
c'est le cas par exemple pour Fabien
Roussel nous le soutenons quand vous
avez un candidat qui ne respecte pas nos
valeurs républicaines nous ne le
soutenons pas voilà donc dans la 11e
circonscription du Pas-de-Calais par
exemple pas de barrage face à Marine Le
Pen qui affront au deuxième tour Marine
tondeuillier une candidate de la nuque
le choix est entre les extrêmes et le
vote blanc mon vote sera donc blanc
voici la consigne de vote donnée par la
candidate de la majorité présidentielle
Alexandrine Pintus dans cette
circonscription du Pas-de-Calais et puis
autre exemple dans le Val-de-Marne
rochsana maraciniano elle appelle bien à
faire barrage mais pas contre l'extrême
droite contre la nuque la ministre des
sports du précédent gouvernement affront
au deuxième tour Rachel kéké ancienne
femme de chambre devenu candidate de
l'union de la gauche je veux rassembler
tous ceux qui veulent faire barrage à
l'extrême gauche au second tour nous
pouvons gagner à écrire Roxana
maracinano sur Twitter les électeurs de
gauche qui eux ont voté manuel Macron au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite
apprécieront
des divergences même dans le cas de la
circonscription de de Marine Le Pen
puisque ça vient appeler la position de
la candidate mais Stanislas Guerini par
exemple il dit qu'il faut faire barrage
à Marine Le Pen c'est un peu ambigu
quand même du côté de la majorité
présidentielle c'est plus de vote c'est
complexe le plus simple aurait été de
dire
c'est ce qu'on avait cru comprendre en
entendant certains ninhup on dit Nupe
c'est bien ça
statuer effectivement on dit
il faudra voir d'ici la prochaine
édition si la nuque existe encore un
autre problème bon ni nup ni RL IRL a
été plus simple et ce à quoi on assiste
vous avez cité plusieurs exemples ça
peut paraître un peu complexe ça l'est
d'ailleurs de cette manière c'est qu'en
quelque sorte dans un certain nombre de
cas les les candidats de la majorité
trient
à ceux qui sont habitués à fréquenter et
qui sont de plus républicains comme vous
sans aucune discussion possible
à ce moment-là c'était des anciens du PS
mais aussi du PC on a cité Fabien
Rousset et des écologistes bon à ce
moment-là pourquoi pas mais après il
faut dire mais les mélanchonistes
j'allais dire en faisant de la provoque
à cette heure-ci c'est pas les islamos
gauchistes dans le vocabulaire
franchement et vous allez pas tomber
dans ce panneau non plus
vous vous êtes journaliste je décris une
situation un peu un peu complexe à
comprendre pour les électeurs mais qui
explique que il est ce tri mais Pierre
va répondre la majorité présidentielle a
perdu sa boussole qui est bien placé
pour donner non mais pardon mais c'est
quoi être républicain ou pas républicain
il y aurait une gauche pas républicaine
si cette gauche pas républicaine qui est
en responsabilité aujourd'hui comme
député comme pas finissent pas encore en
tout cas mais comme merde de certaines
villes il faut les mettre en prison ces
gens s'ils sont des entiers républicains
si ce sont des dangereux
je vous préférez avant avec vos amis
quand vous étiez indiscutablement la
question se posait même pas compte la
première ministre explique aujourd'hui
il y aurait des candidats qui seraient
fréquentables et d'autres qui ne
seraient pas fréquentable donc des
candidats républicains et non
républicains il faudrait qu'elle nous
explique en quoi ces gens ou en tout cas
les gens de la nuque donc qu'elle
reproche de ton tiré plus qu'un il
serait une menace pour la République
parce qu'ils ont pas la même vision
aujourd'hui de la laïcité parce que
c'est bien ça donc il est question
aujourd'hui que ça fait des gens
totalement intéressant par ailleurs je
me souviens que j'enlève elle était
quand même particulièrement attaquée les
deux tours les deux fois en 2017 et en
2022 sur sa ligne de conduite au second
tour en disant pas une voix à l'extrême
droite au mieux je dis bien au mieux
aujourd'hui la majorité présidentielle
dit pas une voix à l'extrême droite on
dit pas voter nu elle dit pas une voix
extrême droite donc ce qu'on reproché
hier aujourd'hui à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui a intégré les mêmes éléments
de langage que Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est
normal et il est normal que dans le camp
de la majorité c'est comme ça que je
l'interprète on est pris en compte on
prenne en compte l'évolution
spectaculaire impressionnante et et
j'ajouterai troublante de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et d'un certain nombre de ceux
qui sont proches de Lui Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
que moi j'ai connu Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
ses amis ses nouveaux alliés ont su se
retirer au régional pour laisser la
droite gouverner des régions contre
l'extrême droite certains s'en
rappellent Renault musulier d'ailleurs
appel à voter pour des candidats de la
nuque quand ils se retrouvent face à des
candidats de l'extrême droite
sortant se désiste dans une triangle
pour laisser le candidat de la nuque
l'emporter face à nous qu'on dirait donc
tout le monde n'a pas perdu ses boussole
mais en revanche il semblerait la
boussole des directions variables selon
les circonscriptions sur le les endroits
sur ce que dit Edouard Philippe risquer
Philippe il prend la parole ce matin il
me donne une interview au Figaro voter
RN m'est impossible mais je ne peux
appeler à voter pour un candidat
insoumis qui s'inscrirait en dehors de
l'idéal républicain tel que je le porte
mais c'est quoi leur idéalerie qui nous
explique alors on a besoin on a besoin
d'un enseignement on a besoin de
pédagogie c'est-à-dire que quand vous
écoutez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
la ministre Roxane a réussi à nous qui
fait un front républicain face à euh
elle va être battue et les seules en
même temps elle est elle demande elle
est fonce
a une candidate qui s'est battue qui a
mené une bataille de plusieurs mois de
grève de plusieurs mois des femmes de
chambre qui ont besoin de porter un
combat qui ont obtenu des accords
historiques dans ces hôtels de luxe elle
se retrouve à dénoncer un front
républicain comme si Rachel Keken
n'était pas républicaine alors qu'elle
porte un combat et un idéal de gauche
qui est classiquement de gauche rien ne
lui reprocher sur son sur son adhésion à
la République et faire de cette figure
un symbole en tout cas de l'anti
républicaine
elle fait une campagne indigne
je suis pas de la polémique c'est elle
qui appelle un front anti République a
laissé
convaincre qu'elle a encore un petit
espoir de gagner à mon avis elle en a
aucun revenir sur Édouard Philippe
puisque il prend la parole on voit non
mais on voit que alors encore une fois
selon les projections ils savent rien
dire l'élection a lieu dimanche on le
répète mais bon on le redit quand même
et Emmanuel Macron de toute façon n'est
pas en capacité d'avoir la majorité sans
cesagner donc sans horizon est-ce
qu'Edouard Philippe va avoir un du coup
un point considérable dans ce
quinquennat
si Emmanuel Macron n'a pas les pures
macronissent si le concept existe en
majorité absolue auprès de lui et il
faudra qu'il
nous des alliances nous des qu'ils
fassent des compromis et effectivement
le cas d'Édouard Philippe enfin la
personnalité de leur Philippe a beaucoup
compté elle contrat de toute façon à
fortiori dans le cas que nous évoquons
du Premier ministre pour revenir à ce
qu'on se disait au début si Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas la majorité absolue
est-ce qu'Elizabeth borne et le bon
profil où est-ce qu'il faut un premier
ministre plus politique pour composer
avec un parlement qui forcément va avoir
un poids considérable il devra
recomposer en fonction d'effectivement
de la nouvelle Assemblée nationale en
fonction des différentes
composantes des rapports de force de
cette hémicycle c'est assez étonnant
effectivement d'avoir constaté de
constater que le au premier on assiste à
un affaissement de la droite
traditionnelle des républicains alors
qu'on pouvait estimer qu'ils auraient pu
conforter dans des secteurs enfin comme
des baronnies locales un certain nombre
de leurs députés visiblement ils vont
perdre beaucoup et en même temps ils
vont jouer un rôle assez décisif au
cours de la prochaine législature soit
dit en passant ça va permettre de
clarifier aussi une situation politique
qui était totalement
US que par ce la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron a totalement avoir avec les
aspirations politiques en tout cas les
lignes politiques que sont celles de la
des républicains donc tout ça va
permettre une clarification une complexe
que ça médaille c'est ce que vous voulez
penser moi je trouve qu'aujourd'hui au
moins il y a une clarification c'est que
au moins les la l'immense majorité des
duels de dimanche prochain vont être des
nups face à des ensemble et qu'on
retrouve un clivage droit de gauche
assez classique
vous avez de borne était la mieux placée
pour pouvoir conduire la réforme des
retraites qu'il annonce pour la rentrée
2023 donc peut-être que la mission qui
est la sienne c'est un an à discuter à
négocier avec les partenaires sociaux et
après la réforme si elle devait passer
par un 49-3 par exemple parce que
compliqué à l'Assemblée nationale
d'avoir un débat et en tout cas d'avoir
une majorité pour voter cette réforme
sans doute qu'après il y aurait des
conséquences qui s'imposeraient et
peut-être un remaniement effectivement a
commencé par Matignon il y aura toute
façon remaniement du gouvernement
au journal de campagne puisque alors il
y a une bataille il y a un politique on
le voit sur le terrain entre la nuque et
les candidats de la majorités présentés
mais il y a aussi une bataille de chips
ça vient oui qui est arrivé en tête du
premier tour des législatives d'après
les résultats officiels Oriane c'est la
majorité présidentielle qui est arrivée
en tête avec 21 000 voix d'avance sur la
nuque sauf que la nuque justement elle
n'est pas du tout d'accord avec ce
chiffre puisqu'elle revendique plus de
240 000 voix d'avance grosse différence
quand même alors explication le
ministère de l'Intérieur n'a pas
comptabilisé les candidats de gauche en
outre-mer ainsi que trois candidats
soutenus par la nuque en métropole hier
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dénoncé une
manœuvre digne je cite d'une république
bananière c'était chez nos confrères de
France 2
je laisse les plaisirs de la bidouille à
Monsieur Darmanin il a fallu lui
arracher qu'on puisse s'appeler par
notre nom en allant au Conseil d'État là
ça fait depuis hier soir qu'il essaye de
tripoter les chiffres il m'enlève des
députés de mon compte tout ça c'est fait
pour masquer le fait que le parti
macroniste à l'erreur a subi une lourde
défaite des accusations balayées par
Elisabeth borne lors d'une réunion
interne que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
pierre Jacquemin une réunion hier dans
le Calvados je cite les propos
d'Elisabeth borne Jean-Luc Mélenchon
prétend vouloir être Premier ministre
c'est surtout le premier menteur
a-t-elle dit assez troupes ça peut
porter cet argument de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ou c'est un peu trop interne
pour que les électeurs s'y intéressent
j'avoue de ne pas très bien comprendre
la raison pour laquelle il commence la
campagne alors qu'il y a une semaine de
campagne importante à mener de commencer
la campagne là-dessus six obtiennent
raison c'est sûr que ce serait un
véritable scandale j'ai le sentiment
quand même que y compris du côté de la
majorité présidentielle je crois avoir
compris que la personnalité comme Damien
Abad qui sont ministres donc a priori
membre de la majorité présidentielle
n'ont pas été comptabilisés par
ministère de l'Intérieur dans les contes
de du côté de la majorité présidentielle
je veux bien entendre que dans leurs
argument il y a beaucoup plus de voix du
côté de la nuque parce que effectivement
un certain nombre d'entre eux n'ont pas
été comptabilisés sur des grosses
circonscriptions notamment je pense en
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais bon je c'est
vrai que ça a été commencé la campagne
sur sur ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit
franchement audible des des gens et
surtout s'ils veulent convaincre les
jeunes notamment et les quartiers
populaires de d'aller voter il va
falloir vraiment rentrer dans la
campagne et mener bataille contre le
contre le gouvernement il peut y avoir
un débat de débat qu'à un nouveau
réclamé Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier sur
France 2 débat des débat sur le fond on
peut chipoter sur si j'ose dire sur 50
000 électeurs de plus de moins selon la
comptabilité c'est la strictement aucune
importante tout le monde sait que que
j'ai envie de dire sportivement avec des
guillemets Mélenchon Jean-Luc Mélenchon
a fait une très belle performance qui
qui n'était pas attendu comme tel ce qui
est important dans le cas de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est la nature de sa
coalition et c'est le contenu de son
programme c'est ça qui est important le
reste c'est c'est c'est peanuts et quand
à la majorité elle a fait un bon
résultat mais si on se remet un an en
arrière ou même six mois en arrière ce
résultat
des sports si on fait 5 ans en arrière
surtout il perdent un million et demi la
majorité quand même
comparaison qui est le réalisatrice de
avant 2017 qui prévoyait l'élection de
d'Emmanuel Macron et six mois avant
cette élection on entendait le cœur des
coalisés de l'opposition ça fait du
monde déclaré il ne sera pas réélu
un score faible pour un président qui
vient d'être élu et dont les
législatives se tiennent juste après
c'est pas faramineux bon encore
fallait-il être réélu et c'était pas
évident quand même effectivement le la
nuque ne va probablement pas sa pesantir
sur ce sur ce débat peut-être qu'elle
n'est pas si sûr de ces AR parce que
faut préciser que cette fois elle n'a
pas l'intention de déposer de recours
alors que c'est ce qu'elle avait fait
pour obtenir l'étiquette de la nuque sur
les bulletins preuve en est que
peut-être
une semaine c'est trop court pour sa
pesantir là-dessus effectivement
d'autant que Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
voulait faire campagne sur le fond il en
appelle aux abstentionnistes et
notamment aux jeunes est-ce que ça peut
porter est-ce que les gens qui se sont
abstenus dimanche peuvent vraiment aller
voter en masse dimanche prochain alors
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait des
démonstrations souvent de force et les
sondeurs nous ont beaucoup expliqué que
les les dernières élections ont montré
que les électeurs se décidaient souvent
au dernier moment dans les deux derniers
jours ils ont mené des campagnes avec
énormément d'associations des quartiers
populaires donc j'imagine qu'ils vont
savoir mobiliser un certain nombre de
électeurs oui vous l'avez dit 70% des
moins de 35 ans n'ont pas voté ne sont
pas allé voter dimanche donc il y a un
véritable enjeu aujourd'hui à aller
solliciter les voix de de ces des
quartiers populaires mais plus
généralement de la jeunesse Jean-Luc
Mélenchon hier dans son intervention au
journal de France 2 un tout petit peu
serrer la vis c'est un peu faire
entendre sa colère vis-à-vis de la
jeunesse en disant que vous pouvez pas
voir en même temps critiquer la méthode
de de sélection de parcoursup et pas
vous révolter et pas aller dans les
urnes pour voter pour ceux qui
supprimeraient la réforme de parcoursup
vous pouvez pas non plus dire que vous
avez pas l'argent pour aller faire pour
acheter vos pour faire vos courses et
faire des colis alimentaires et en même
temps ne pas les voter pour ceux qui
vous proposent une allocation
universelle de jeunesse 2000 un peu plus
de 1000 euros donc il a essayé de
mobiliser les jeunes je sais pas si ça
peut marcher en tout cas ce que je crois
c'est que la campagne de second tour est
une campagne de confrontation d'idées de
projet en tout cas j'espère que le le
parti de la majorité présidentielle
finira par accepter le débat parce que
c'est extrêmement important que les
Français sachent pour qui ils doivent
aller voter et c'est aussi une manière
pour eux de les inciter à aller voter
pour voir qu'il y a deux projets qui
s'opposent
mobiliser les abstentionnistes plus
largement c'est pas la dernière carte de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce que quelles
sont ses réserves de voix maintenant
c'est fait au premier tour il a peu de
voix il a peu de réserves de voix sur sa
gauche il peut compter peut-être sur une
démobilisation d'électorat à droite qui
a vu son candidat préféré premier tour
éliminer le premier tour qui peut être
démobilisé pas avoir envie de donner une
majorité présidentielle à Emmanuel
Macron il peut y avoir une partie des
électeurs on les disait tout à l'heure
de Marine Le Pen qui veut créer un bloc
anti Macron mais qui peut aussi exister
du côté de Mélenchon et puis ce qu'il a
su faire par le passé encore une fois
c'est une mobiliser l'électorat
abstentionniste les jeunes les quartiers
populaires et ça on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une surprise effectivement dimanche
prochain il fait de sa élection à
référendum anti Macron enfin en contre
sa politique il a redire pas contre sa
personne mais qu'on sa politique ça peut
porter mais je pense que à droite et à
gauche je vais reprendre le clivage
classique à droite et à gauche on a
raison de d'appeler aux d'appeler les
abstentionnistes à ce à se dégeler et à
venir il pourrait y avoir des surprises
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut voir des
électeurs du premier tour se réfugier
cette fois dans l'abstention et des
peut-être sur les marges mais c'est pas
négligeable des électeurs qui s'étaient
abstenus choisir pour rallier le drapeau
compliqué le mon point de vue de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de sa coalition ou
pour faire barrage Mélenchon et donner
un coup de main à une majorité qui a une
résultat inégal venir cette fois votre
essai de nouveaux abstentionnistes et
des abstentionnistes d'un autre côté qui
cette fois ils vont c'est possible en
tout cas sous cet angle là Mélenchon a
raison de dire c'est du volontarisme
politique à gauche a été assez peu
habitué aux victoires et le fait que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est frôlé le second
tour la présidentielle mais aussi un bon
succès avec sa nouvelle union populaire
au premier tour de législatives peut
remobiliser un électorat qui se dit ah
tiens il y a peut-être une fenêtre de
tir un trou de souris comme dirigeant
mais ça peut exister et on va parler de
la droite la droite qui est arrivée en
4e position de ces législatives et qui
s'est réuni hier elle fait un peu profil
bas oui c'est difficile de continuer à
exister quand on perd son statut de
première force d'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale avec 11,3% des
voix au premier tour des législatives
les républicains et leurs alliés ne
devraient obtenir selon les projections
que 50 à 80 sièges contre une centaine
de députés aujourd'hui donc le parti
sauve les meubles mais on l'a dit tout à
l'heure il va falloir qu'il
redéfinissent sa ligne politique est-ce
qu'il faut devenir une force d'appoint
d'un gouvernement sans majorité absolue
ou au contraire s'affirmer dans
l'opposition et bien comme tout le monde
n'était pas vraiment d'accord le parti a
choisi de ne pas vraiment choisir hier
après cette réunion dont vous parliez
Oriane une réunion du comité stratégique
Christian Jacob a résumé la ligne à
suivre celle de l'opposition utile en
aucun cas une force d'appoint une
opposition une opposition déterminée
mais une position utile c'est-à-dire pas
dans le blocage des institutions pas
dans les outrances pas pour bloquer le
pays est capable d'amender des textes si
on trouve un peu coincé les républicain
aujourd'hui Dominique de montfallon pas
dans l'opposition mais un peu dans
l'opposition quand même difficulté il y
a des tempéraments à l'intérieur des
républicains qui poussent les uns dans
une direction et les autres dans une
autre ce que vous avez suggéré à juste
titre si je puis me permettre
mais par ailleurs quand on songe si on
prend les sur 20 ans ou 30 ans ce qui
était les républicains avancent d'autres
dénominations ce qu'ils étaient ce
qu'elles représentaient ils se
retrouvent aujourd'hui à dire non on
sera pas rallier la majorité on veut pas
être une simple force d'appoint c'est
difficile de gérer
la pauvreté
moi je reviens au Maroc c'est à dire que
je j'ai le sentiment et quand on regarde
honnêtement lucide de manière lucide les
programmes de la droite et le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron quand on voit
qu'Emmanuel Macron veut réduire les
dépenses publiques qui veut réformer la
retraite à 65 ans ça c'est clair c'est
pas le cas Mélenchon donc je veux dire
là on avait quand même deux familles qui
sont sensiblement proches et donc je
pars les postures individuelles la
nécessité de faire survivre un parti
politique alors qu'on est tous d'accord
a priori que les parties ne sont pas une
fin en soi quand même se sont un moyen
d'atteindre des objectifs je vois pas
que ces familles ne se rejoignent pas à
un moment donné alors sans doute tout
savoir imposer peut-être qu'il y a une
partie de la républicains qui peut faire
à ne pas faire alliance avec Macron pour
pouvoir rejoindre le blog plus
identitaire plus nationaliste ça va être
compliqué pour eux de prendre des
décisions mais Emmanuel Macron va avoir
besoin de
[Musique]